…testicles.
Taxi!
Maybe life
is still worth living.
-What?
-Hello, boy.
-Mum.
-What, love?
-I'm having a bath.
-Good boy.
Bloody steamy in here,
isn't it?
Yeah, told him
he does it too hot.
-What?
-Bad for his testicles.
-Makes you sterile.
-Wow. Do you mind?
Yep, they do look red, mate.
Oh yeah. Put a bit
of cold on them, James.
Can we stop talking
about my bloody testicles?
They're fine.
-Some cake, Brian?
-Oh, yes please.
-Thank you.
-James?
I'm having a fucking bath!
-Is that a yes or a no?
-What kind of cake?
Chocolate gateau
with crumbled flakes on top.
Mm.
Yes, then, please.
I've got to get
my own place.
You can move in with me.
You know what?
Let's do it.
Time for me to become a man.
Will you help me break
the news to my mum?
Ah!
Oh, I got him!
-Oh, my God!
-Prat!
Maybe life
is still worth living.
-Oh, my God.
-That's not funny, actually.
-That's just…
-Well, I disagree.
Tony, can you clear this up,
please?
No.
Hurt my elbow as well.
You got a lock on.
Yeah, I'm in bed.
It's Ken.
Yeah, I guessed that.
I've had an idea for a new
showbiz gossip piece
called Careless Whisper.
Okay, tell me tomorrow.
Yeah, it's basically a list
of all the people I know
who've claimed they've
wanked off George Michael.
He's right,
they're building their brand
on the promise that you can
eat as much as you want.
Is the babyccino--
You can't suddenly renege
on the deal, because someone
eats too much or too often.
Or you got to change
the rules, you know?
For everyone, though.
-Be upfront about it.
-The quinoa?
You love the quinoa.
-There's no Arno any more.
-Have you done a poo?
-A big, farmyard poo?
-Oh, for fuck's sake.
-You okay?
-Yeah, why?
Well, you just said,
"For fuck's sake," so…
What, and you assumed
something had annoyed me?
Like someone making
unnecessary noise.
Oh, shit.
He's a baby.
Yeah, but he's not the one
making all the noise, is he?
You are.
Well, to keep him amused,
because if he was crying,
that would annoy people,
wouldn't it?
No it wouldn't,
because he's a baby.
You making all the noise
is the annoying bit.
They're just sounds.
They shouldn't concern you.
You're talking
to your friend.
I'm talking to my child.
But you can't hear
every word I'm saying.
-Can you?
-Oh, so what?
There's noise around.
That's life.
Okay. Good point.
Who's a noisy prick?
You are. You're a big,
annoying prick.
-That's pathetic.
-I'm talking to my friend.
Well, you're saying things
others don't want to hear.
So are you,
but you don't care, so…
Yeah, you're
a big, loud cock.
Yes you are!
You're a hipster,
gnome-looking, fucking twat.
You big, annoying,
loud cock in public.
You are. You're a cunt.
I'm gonna, I'm gonna…
You got a big belly.
You cunt.
You big, fucking cunt.
You… big, fucking… cunt!
They're just sounds.
Um, so you're a lawyer?
Uh, yes. A barrister.
-Right.
-You?
No.
-What?
-No, I'm not a barrister.
Okay. Um, what is your job?
Oh, my job?
Um…
Okay, I'm not gonna lie.
I'm…
a doctor.
-Wow.
-Yeah.
-You got a practice?
-No need.
Done all that. Got my
certificate and everything.
Uh, she's a doctor.
Oh, off duty.
-What?
-I'm off duty.
She's fine. Thought so.
Why didn't you help her?
-Heard you're feeling down.
-Yeah.
Yeah? Talk to me.
Well, everyone knows
what Roxy does for a living.
-I'm just embarrassed.
-Embarrassed?
You're probably
delivering to blokes
that have
actually shagged her.
At the very least.
What do you mean?
Well, I doubt
it's a straightforward shag
if they're paying for it.
Get my drift?
think about it, boy.
Imagine all the things
she has to do.
Missionary...
Boring.
Turn round.
Let me see that ass.
All of that. Scrabble round.
Get your mouth
round my naughty lolly.
Watch those gnashers.
Keep it coming.
Ah, that was lovely.
There you go,
take the money.
Go back to
your postman boyfriend.
I always wish I had a brick
to put
through the fucking window.
That would be the last piece
of the jigsaw, wouldn't it?
You actually carrying
a brick around with you,
hovering around
zebra crossings.
Yeah, it would be
a social service.
-I'd be like Batman.
-…but mental.
Yeah.
Maybe I'm not grieving.
Maybe I'm just an asshole.
I just like
punishing people.
Classic vigilante story,
isn't it?
I am like Batman. Or Dexter.
He was a serial killer,
but his dad taught him
only to kill bad people.
But he was just mental.
Or Spiderman.
His uncle got killed
and he went
fucking sorting out
bad people.
Didn't he get bitten
by a spider?
-I don't remember the uncle.
-Yeah.
And then he made himself
a poncey outfit at home.
I wouldn't bother with that.
Just wear my own clothes.
So, uh…
Also, I would
fucking batter Spiderman.
Puny little twat
in tight kids' pajamas.
-Got Spidey senses, though.
-Yeah?
Stomp, squashed.
Dr. Barnaby Love M.D.
I combined medical drama
with erotic fiction.
Like me to read
a bit from my latest one?
Yep.
"Open Wide."
Not that bit.
That's filth, that bit.
Let's have a look.
Oh, here's a good bit.
So, Dr. Barnaby is
operating on someone
that all the top surgeons
in the world said
could not be saved.
But Dr. Barnaby disagrees.
"Nurse Stacy
mopped his brow.
'Is that better, doctor?'
Their eyes meet
over the top of the masks
you have to wear
in operating theatres.
'Please, call me Barnaby.'
She blushes.
'Okay, we're going in.'
He injects the medicine into
the patient's main artery.
'That should do the trick,'
said Barnaby,
'Okay, stitch him up, nurse.
Dinner later?'
'Oh, yes please,' she said,
'See you at eight.'"
-Does he live?
-Who, dear?
The patient.
Oh, I didn't say.
Didn't bother with that.
I'm sure he's fine
if they got the medicine
into the main artery.
Exactly.
I wonder why all the top
surgeons around the world
didn't think of that.
Well, Dr. Barnaby's special,
isn't he?
He's best in the world.
A randy bugger, too,
which never hurts.
-Good. Take a picture.
-Yep.
You can't have a pint of
beer before playing squash.
Course you can. Go on
Oh, you're bringing it
in with you, are you?
-In case I get thirsty.
-Unbelievable.
Oh… Hello.
There you are.
Oh, that stinks. Oh, my God.
Right.
-Okay, you ready?
-Yep.
-Level.
-Tits.
-Well… Okay…
-Oh, is that…?
You can't shout "tits"
before someone serves.
What if I've got Tourette's?
-Oh!
-Come on!
-Oh, you just…
-Unlucky!
-Ah!
This is ridiculous.
-Yeah, all right.
-It's fizzy, isn't it?
Is it?
Oh, my God.
-I feel sick, actually.
-Absolutely gross.
Oh, my God.
Come on.
-I mean, that's disgusting.
-What?
What?
What do you…?
-This. Oh, my God.
-Don't slip on it.
What are you talking about?
It's in the middle.
How am I not going
to fucking slip on it?
This is even worse.
What is?
You sat there doing
a fucking word search.
Hm. Used to be porn, mate.
Stack that high.
Those days are gone.
See, five years ago,
I could have knocked one out
and got you
right in the face.
I'm a professional actor
and director,
I'll have you know.
What you been in?
Taxi Driver: The Musical,
Wigan.
-Any good?
-Oh, well, you tell me.
Are you talking to me?
Because I'm talking to you
I don't see anyone else
You could be
Fucking talking to
Bang, bang!
I'm a taxi driver
I drive through the night
Picking up who I like
Bang, bang!
I'm a taxi driver
If you're dealing crack
Then you'll get one
In the back from me
Tonight
Taxi!